[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
VIC FRYZEL: Hey guys, welcome
back to Google Developer Live.
I'm Vic.
I work on the Google
Drive SDK team.
Today, what I'm going to be
doing is walking through the
Quickstart sample for the
Drive SDK and Ruby.
So today I'm going to show you
how to write a command line
application that will upload
a file to Google Drive.
So this is pretty
straightforward.
The entire tutorial takes five
minutes or less to really run
through yourself.
There's just a few key steps
that we have to do.
So here on my screen, I've
got the Google Drive SDK
documentation open,
specifically
our Quickstart guide.
And there's a lot of text here,
but the primary points
are that you need to enable the
Drive API for a Google API
Console project.
That pretty much lets your
application just
access the Drive API.
You need to install the Google
Ruby client library, set up
the sample, and run
the sample.
So let's just dive in.
The first thing is open the
Google API Console, and then
create a new project.
So I'm going to create
one here.
I'm going to call this
Google Developers
Live, and Create Project.
This just takes a second to
create the new project.
And here it is.
So you'll notice that most
of the services are off.
What we have to do is enable
the Drive API.
Click this.
And then, that's it
for that section.
The other thing that we have
to do in the API Console is
create an OAuth 2.0 client ID,
and what this is going to do
is allow our command line
application to actually make
requests to the API that have
been authorized by a user.
So I'm going to create
the client ID.
Again, I'm going to call it
Google Developers Live.
And then I'm going
to click Next.
So this is important.
We're not writing a
web application.
We're writing an installed
application, so this is an
application that doesn't
run in a web browser.
So let's select this.
And then it's not an Android
or iOS application, it's
Other, and then I'm going
to create the client ID.
All right, so here it is.
This is our client ID, and this
is our client secret.
We're going to need these
in just a minute.
Coming back to the
documentation, the next thing
that we have to do is install
the Google API
client library for Ruby.
So this is pretty much
just a Ruby gem.
I'm going to come here
and paste it.
I've actually already got
it installed, and I need
superuser permissions to install
it and stuff, so I'm
not going to run that command,
but just trust me
that I've run it.
And once that's installed, we
need to set up the sample.
So, under Ruby here, the only
thing that we need to do is
copy and paste this source code
into quickstart.rb, which
is the name of the file that
we're going to run.
So I've got that here locally.
You can see, this is
the exact same.
And then the next thing that we
have to do is replace these
templates with an actual
client ID in secret.
So these are in the API Console
for the installed
application, so let me select
this one, and there's the
client ID, and then we
replace this one
with the client secret.
And that's it.
So I'm going to save it, and
then we'll run it, and after
we run it once, we're going to
walk through the source code.
So to run it-- this is also
in the documentation--
we just come down a little bit
further, and you can see all
you have to do is run
Ruby quickstart.rb.
So paste to that--
oh, oops.
Before I forget, let me also
go into the fact that we're
going to upload a file, so
we need a file to upload.
I actually have one here
called document.txt.
It says "Hello world" inside.
Nothing fancy.
So again, let me run
the quickstart.
So you see some warnings
appear.
Just ignore those.
Those are because my Ruby
installation is a
little messed up.
But no big deal.
It's still functioning fine.
So here, what we need to
do is paste this URL
into our web browser.
So I come here, and I paste.
So here we see the OAuth 2.0
authorization page for our API
project, Google Developers Live,
and it's asking me to
view and manage the files and
documents in Google Drive.
If a user's curious, they can
expand this and see what else
is going on.
So I'm going to click Allow
Access, and because this is
for an installed application,
what it's going to do is give
me an authorization code that I
have to take from this text
box and paste back to
the application.
So once I paste that here and
hit Enter, that's it.
So here, we have the document
ID for our file
and then the title.
These were returned from the
Drive SDK back to the Ruby
client library, and then we
printed them out in our
application.
So let's take a look at Google
Drive, and I'll show you that
that actually worked.
So here, I'm searching for my
document, which is the name of
the document we uploaded,
and there's nothing.
But if I refresh, here it is.
So I click on this and
give it a second.
It says "Hello world." So that's
the content of our text
file, so we know
that it works.
Let's just now take a look
through the source code and
see what's going on.
So if I--
then quickstart.rb.
So at the top here, we're just
importing some libraries, and
then setting some constants here
primarily the client ID
in secret, and then the
OAuth scope that
we're going to request.
Here, we requested the full
drive scope, so this allows us
to pretty much access any
part of the Drive API.
There are other scopes that are
probably more appropriate,
but because hypothetically this
application might in the
future download files or
something like that, or work
with a user's entire
drive corpus, we
request the full scope.
And then also we need the
redirect URI, which is
currently set to out of band,
which is why we had to copy
and paste that authorization
code.
Then we create a new API client
and load the drive API.
Pretty straightforward.
We request authorization, so
we set up some parameters
here, and then we get the URI
from client.authoriza
tion.authorizationuri.
We print that to the screen.
This is the thing that the user
will copy and paste into
their web browser, and once they
paste it, we're going to
request that they enter the
authorization code, and
client.authorization.code equals
what they gave, and
then we're going to fetch
the access token.
Pretty straightforward.
The last thing that we have
to do is actually
just insert the file.
So here, we're creating the new
file with this metadata.
So here's the title and the
description and the MIME type.
And then, here's the media
content that we're going to
attach to that metadata.
So document.txt, and we're
saying that its
type is text plain.
And here's the result.
Here is where we actually
upload this
file to Google Drive.
We're just doing client.execute,
and we're
doing drive.files.insert, and
we're attaching some extra
parameters here.
Once we do that, result contains
a JSON object or a
JSON representation of the API
response, and result.data dot
whatever is going to have
metadata about the individual
file that we uploaded.
So result.data.id is the ID of
the file, and title is title
of the file.
There's other stuff in here
that's not too important at
the moment.
So that's pretty much it
for the application.
So once we've got that done,
we can actually improve the
sample quite a bit.
We could do some other things,
primarily this stuff, like
copying and pasting this URL
into the browser, then
clicking Allow Access, then
copying and pasting the
authorization code back
into the application.
That's just tedious for the
user, so there are a couple of
ways around that.
What we want to do usually is
open the web browser for the
user, firstly, so that they land
on the authorization page
without having to copy
and paste the URL.
The other thing we usually want
to do is spin up a web
server locally on the user's
computer just for a few
minutes while the user browses
to the authorization URL.
And then what we can do is set
a redirect URI so that when
Google receives the Allow Access
click from the user,
Google will redirect
the user's browser
back to local host.
And once they do that, you can
land here on your own web
browser and get the URI of
the request which has the
authorization code in it.
And with that authorization
code, you can use that to then
upgrade to a request and
an access token.
So that's a much better user
experience where the user
doesn't have to copy and paste
some stuff that they might not
necessarily understand.
Some other stuff that you
could do is make this
application work for more file
types besides text files.
So at the moment, if we come
back to quickstart.rb, you can
see here that we manually set
the MIME type, but you could
do some more intelligent
determination of what the MIME
type of the file is before
uploading it.
Another thing we can do is
extend just the general
functionality of this
command line sample.
We could do things like allow
the user to download a file
with the command line sample, or
we do things like cache the
refresh and access tokens into a
secure data store locally on
the user's computer.
So in Linux, you might use
a keystore, for instance.
So those are just a couple of
things that we could do.
If you're really looking more
towards writing a web app that
integrates with the Google Drive
user interface, then I
highly recommend you take a
look at our other samples,
which are back here in
the documentation
under Example Apps.
So here, we have a full
set of example apps.
So here's the Ruby one for
writing an example application
called DrEdit, which is a
text editor for the web.
And that's very much more
advanced in that it allows you
to integrate your application
into the Google Drive user
interface so that a user can
interact with individual files
using your application, and it
does a few more advanced
things that just take a little
bit longer to get started.
Certainly more than
five minutes.
So that would be a
good next step.
That's pretty much it, though.
So this has been the Google
Drive SDK Quickstart for Ruby.
I'm Vic.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]